[Applause]
we come to you for one of the truly
iconic stadiums in the NFL
don't you dare look at
Bay Wisconsin no team means more
as a graded gold made their way out of
the historic tunnel they're ready to go
as they get set to match up with the
Miami Dolphins
the Madden series aims to be a
true-to-life representation of the
popular American sport of football and
Madden 19 is refined step forward with
advancements across the board there are
some issues hanging over from past games
and the franchise updates are not as big
and exciting as you might expect but
Madden 19 with it's capable frostbite
engine and it's compelling longshot
story mode remains the best most
complete Madden game to date on the
field
Madden's gameplay has never looked or
handled better and this is due in part
to a new system EA calls real player
motion one of the biggest pieces of this
is the new one cut feature for ball
carriers that allows them to change
direction quickly and with a burst of
speed to get around a defender you can
also perform hesitation moves that can
make a big difference in those crucial
moments when you see an opening or a gap
and it's thrilling to successfully
execute a run establishing the run game
can be critical and it's nice to see
Madden 19 make running responsive fun
and representative of what you see in
real NFL games to balance out the new
tactics for ball carriers Madden 19 adds
a new strafe first mechanic for
defenders that helps you get into
position to stop a big play and in a
further step toward simulating actual
NFL games Madden 19 lets you choose a
custom celebration after a touchdown or
a big defensive play with individual and
team based options it gives Madden a
more authentic feel
field and score on the opening drive
on the presentation side Madden 19 uses
the frostbite engine again to great
effect character models are now more
lifelike while small things like player
sweat the way bodies crunch and recoil
after big hits sunspots pouring onto the
field at dusk and weather elements like
rain and snow get even closer to
replicating real life the graphics look
better but the physics can still be
really weird at times arms Bend in ways
they shouldn't character models fuse
together and seeing the crowd jump in
unison can be really strange on the
brighter side the menus have been
updated and now are sleeker and less
cluttered Madden 19's commentating is a
big bright spot thanks to excellent
performances by the play-by-play and
Colour duo of Brandon Gordon and Charles
Davis their banter succeeds thanks to
their football acumen as well as their
ability to emulate real NFL broadcast
booths and shoot the breeze on seemingly
random topics you'll hear at least one
Seinfeld reference be very careful about
what speed they're going to play my
music teacher back in New Paltz misses
my favorite bag Lisa said don't go
prestissimo
[Applause]
when you really want to go at a nice
slow deliberate pace I am speechless I
am without speech Madden 19's commentary
will be updated on a regular basis with
new dialogue lines that reflect what
happens in the real NFL once the season
kicks off later this month however it
remains to be seen if the commentators
will tackle controversial subjects like
the kneeling policy or other current
events
Madden's commentary is known for getting
stale so I hope the new lines are
substantial and fun to listen to another
big part of Madden is the franchise mode
last year's game was frustratingly light
on advancements and improvements there
are some new tweaks this year though
they might not resonate with everyone
one of the more notable new features is
what's called the archetype progression
system this adds different styles to
positions unless you continue to build
and expand your players over the course
of one or multiple seasons the XP you
earn in games gives you skill points
that you can then spend to upgrade one
of the archetypes for your player
instead of assigning them to specific
attributes as you could in previous
games this can feel frustrating as it
effectively limits the amount of fine
control you have to shape your players
another way to play Madden is through
the card based madden ultimate team mode
and it's stocked with things to do this
year in addition to the standard
challenges of which there are more than
100 there are solo battles where you can
go up against other fan-created mutt
squads in weekly tournaments well there
will also be a playlist for mutt squads
made by EA SPORTS developers NFL players
and celebrities it's a thrill to take on
a different squad each playthrough in
solo battles and I can see myself
returning again and again to this mode
to see how my team stacks up already a
deep and robust mode mutt adds the brand
new mutt squad challenges where you and
two others take on the CPU in a series
of online football challenges provided
your teammates know what they're doing
this is a mode that delivers yet another
compelling reason to play mutt online
and keep coming back madden ultimate
team still pushes you towards
microtransactions and that may be a
concern for some but it remains as
exciting and satisfying as ever to put
together a fantasy team where Tom Brady
could throw a touchdown pass to Jerry
Rice it's been a year now since Wade
made a name for himself on the hit show
long shot but now he's been signed by
the Dallas Cowboys and a year ago I
would have said Wade's got a shot at a
decent NFL career but let's be honest
this last year has been really rough on
him on the story side Madden 19 brings
back the long shot mode which was a
breath of fresh air last year the new
called longshot homecoming picks up with
Devin Wade having a tough time in the
Dallas Cowboys training camp with Colt
Cruz struggling through life in Mathis
and getting blindsided by a major life
event the voice acting and performances
of all the major characters weight in
particular are solid ei also recruited
celebrities like Rob Schneider Ron
Cephas Jones
Jimmy Tatro and Joey King for the mug
and they turn in memorable performances
homecoming story is one of pain and
struggle loss and redemption and how
football really doesn't matter when
compared to issues at home and in life
homecoming
like the original longshot before it has
bold ambitions in terms of the story it
tells and the feelings it wants to evoke
but it doesn't always work out at times
it can be uneven and inconsistent in its
tone coming across as hokey and
ham-handed and in what is a surprising
move ei almost completely dropped the
telltale style dialogue options from the
first iteration it's a real shame that
ei moved away from this in favor of a
more traditionally structured story that
being said the narrative will pull you
through and at just about four hours in
length you may finish it in one sitting
despite a significant difficulty spike
at the end I had a fun time playing
through Devon and Colts story which
reached a satisfying and heartwarming
conclusion Madden 19 is an excellent
football game that improves on last
year's entry in almost every way there
are problems but there has never been a
football game that more authentically
represents the NFL than this in terms of
presentation controls and depth
[Applause]
Derick are taking it in from seven yards
away
and to me that's how I allow you to
start grinning widely on your sideline I
think they pretty much locked this one
away
yeah that's the clencher the proverbial
icing on the cake